i
[Música]
ah
en argentina la cuarentena para intentar
contener el avance de la pandemia de
kobe 19 ya supera los 5 meses de
duración hubo momentos en que fue más
estricta y también en los que hubo mayor
acatamiento son dos cosas que van de la
mano una hace posible a la otra pero
cuando hay un agotamiento muy grande en
la población es difícil mantener en su
lugar las medidas más estrictas de hecho
aquí en la ciudad de buenos aires y en
el gran buenos aires que son distritos
que concentran un porcentaje muy
importante de la población del país la
cuarentena se ha ido suavizando a medida
que los ciudadanos han comenzado a salir
más y también a realizar un mayor número
de actividades económicas a veces lo han
hecho después de la decisión oficial de
relajar la cuarentena y a veces lo han
hecho antes además aquí en argentina ha
habido protestas en contra de la
cuarentena en las que se han expresado
diferentes posiciones desde las quejas
por el impacto económico que la medida
ha tenido sobre la población hasta en
algunos casos también quejas vinculadas
con teorías conspirativas que nada
tienen que ver con lo que está
ocurriendo en la realidad pero en todo
caso un porcentaje de la población que
no es el mayoritario ha salido a
manifestarse y todo esto
de que se hace muy difícil mantener una
cuarentena estricta sin posiblemente un
proceso de relajamiento y de apertura
progresivo
[Música]
desde que el presidente de donald trump
decretó el estado de emergencia nacional
se escucharon muchas voces críticas
contra esas medidas restrictivas se
decían que eran exageradas a pesar de lo
que decían y recomendaban a los
funcionarios de salud del centro para el
control y prevención de enfermedades por
ejemplo aquí en florida cuyo motor
económico es el turismo pues los
restaurantes hoteles y otros negocios se
vieron obligados a cerrar prácticamente
desde el principio muchos grupos
salieron a la calle los fines de semana
para pedir a la administración pues que
suavizada las medidas restrictivas
porque consideraban que estaba siendo un
duro golpe para la economía a pesar de
todo ya han bajado el número de casos
positivos continúan las medidas ahora
haya muchos más suavizadas aunque
continúan habiendo grupos que dicen que
las medidas son abusivas por ejemplo con
el uso del tapabocas
[Música]
el instituto de salud pública alemán
indicó el mes pasado que una de las
razones que explican el aumento en el
número de casos de coronavirus en este
país es la negligencia en referencia a
las personas que ya no respetan de
manera estricta las reglas de higiene y
de distanciamiento social y esto es algo
que se puede ver de manera clara de
manera particular en las noches en las
grandes ciudades como aquí en la capital
berlín donde a veces pareciera que ya no
hay más pandemia los bares están
repletos y hay poco respeto por esas
reglas de higiene y de distanciamiento
social un caso concreto las autoridades
berlinesas recientemente detectaron 80
infracciones en un solo bar en una sola
noche cuando un grupo de personas se
reunió para ver un partido de fútbol de
la liga de campeones este es un tema que
claramente preocupa a las autoridades y
no solamente aquí en berlín sino también
en el resto del país pues han indicado
que mientras no haya una vacuna contra
el coronavirus la responsabilidad de
mantener los números bajos en este país
recae sobre todos los ciudadanos
[Música]